i'm sure tommy knows that
yeah you ever pissed anybody off tommy
every uh celebrities me yeah
uh yeah i got nailed real early was
by jack nicholson i was uh i was
i was at this party in hollywood
and uh lou weather we had just signed
with lou out there
in fact i think we had a record out then
yeah we did
and uh yeah so cheech and i were the the
new kids on the block you know where the
new the latest thing
and we went to a party uh at lew others
and there was uh
everybody the stones were there and half
the beatles were there
and all these famous people jack
nicholson wow
and so i wanted to get i smoke a joint
so i asked lou you know where can i
smoke it he said i'll go in the bedroom
so i go in the bedroom and there's i
looked at and
you know i light up the joint i looked
down and there's john lennon
sitting on the floor by the bed
and i look wow john lennon
hey so i immediately offered him the
joint he goes oh no
no i can't smoke uh we got immigration
problems you know
and so just then the door opens in
income rod stewart
and he's over there and he's combing his
hair
in the mirror you know so they offered a
toke and he said
you know my voice i can't do that and so
then i
and anyway it smelled really rank you
know
so i put it out and then i walked down
into the hallway
and run into jack nicholson and
wow and i just saw him in a movie the
last detail
and in the movie he plays like a major
or something anyway
but there was one scene that fascinated
me i i couldn't get over it
where he's in the mirror and he's
combing his hair
and the the the scene went on for a long
time
and he's got no hair he's got a little
military cut
and but he he kept combing it throughout
the whole scene
and was it was mesmerizing you know so i
asked jack
you know i didn't say a big fan or
nothing nice jack that scene you know in
the in the last detail man
you're combing your hair you know with
your comb and your hair
it's taking forever and and you've got
no hair to comb
and you're still combing it you know and
i said
was that i had liv did you make that up
on the spot or was that in the script
and he said he just looked at me like i
just
dumped put a dump on his shoe you know
and he walked by me excuse me you're in
my weight yes
pushed me aside and just just walked
away
it was it was a big yep
it was it
stopped me from talking like i knew
these people
you know thanks so much for watching
this clip
and if you drink coffee you need a
mug shot mug that's my first ever mug
shot
and this mug is available on amazon as
well as at stevo.com
so go ahead and click the link in the
description below this is what you're
going to find
and grab yourself a mug shot mug
yeah dude yeah
dude